so Interstellar is one of Christopher
Nolan's most ambitious movies this is
pretty much his 2001. the director has a
number of references to that and other
movies throughout this video we're going
to be breaking it all down and talking
about the hidden details in it Easter
eggs and the true meaning of the movie
along with its ending now you can tell
from Christopher Nolan's movies that
he's absolutely obsessed with time it's
laced throughout a lot of his work with
more obvious examples like tenet down to
more subtle things like his
non-chronological storytelling Memento
made the director a name and this told
the main story backwards so that we
could be hit with lots of twists and
reveals Inception had time dilation as
we got deeper into a dream and both
Batman Begins in the prestige use
flashbacks throughout Dunkirk had
different periods of time being shown to
us and in interstellar time is almost
like a force fighting against the
protagonists at its core Interstellar to
me has always been about a father
sacrificing the time he has with his
children in order to do his work I'm
sure this is something a lot of of
people can relate to and it leads to one
of the most devastating scenes in the
film now the theory of relativity is
laced throughout with time means
something that characters experience is
moving differently depending on where
they are however this idea of time
extends beyond that and the ship that
endurance is even shaped like the face
of a clock we can see that it has a
circular design with compartments going
around it in total there are 12 of these
subtly hinging to us about this idea I
think the most devastating planet that
they travel to is the water one where we
learn that the speed they experience
time could cost them years on Earth this
is reflected in the soundtrack too and
the ticks you can hear in the music give
the idea that time is working against
them
bacon
however these ticks happen at the time
they do for a specific reason every one
of them happens at one and a quarter
seconds exactly broken down this equates
to one tick equaling one day on Earth so
you can literally hear the day sticking
away as the crew search for what's
happened on the planet I didn't actually
discover this myself so if you're the
person who did then write it in the
comments no one claims it then just give
this Easter egg to everyone and Well
Done mate give yourself a pat on the
back for that amazing detail this planet
was ventured to by Miller who sent back
a signal saying it was safe to travel to
they clearly hadn't experienced the
waves yet and thought it was safe which
is why they gave the green light due to
the time dilation we learned that Miller
likely died minutes before their arrival
and knowing this at the start of the
scene actually adds a lot to it if you
zoom in you can make out this happening
as the ship descends from the clouds
when they land the waves that we see up
in the distance behind them are the same
ones that have just killed Miller the
Miller killer if you will now another
nice deep tell as they come down is that
the Ripples and the waves are moving in
different directions this is because of
the planet's proximity to a black hole
which is causing lots of gravitational
anomalies it's even possible that the
planet could be safe but due to strong
gravity field from the hull everything
is being pulled in the black hole in the
movie is something that's actually
groundbreaking and it was built to be a
scientifically accurate as it could be
it's a full render of Einstein's
equations sped out in IMAX on a 32 000
core render from a farm that worked 24
hours per frame this means that each
frame featuring it took roughly 100
hours to render the end result was so
accurate that it actually brought forth
real scientific insight and so far three
papers have been published on the
information gain from it this obviously
wouldn't have been available in
Einstein's day but rendering it this way
aloud for scientists to study a
representation of it inside a computer
named Gargantua this means giant or
colossal they explain it by folding
paper and using a pencil to show how one
can travel from one point to another the
first time I saw this example was back
in Event Horizon and Jane Foster
mentioned both this movie and that when
discussing it in Thor love and thunder
now the movie opens with Murphy's
bookcase and some dust falling from a
shelf out of view due to the events that
happen at the end we know this is caused
by Koopa and this is the first anomaly
that brings in the Drone now the
bookcase itself is actually filled with
ones that share themes with the movie
there's the Stephen King book the Stan
which is about a post-apocalyptic World
in which the last humans are trying to
survive can tell it's that book
instantly off the spine because dear me
size of that story everyone who's made
it through that book no knows what I'm
talking about and there's a wrinkle in
time which talks about higher dimensions
and it also includes a tesseract there's
flatland or Romance of many dimensions
Labyrinth the go-between and selected
poems which deal with time and space
lastly when Cooper is watching his past
self leave Murph we can see on the Shelf
near his head the book Lois Larry's the
willoughbys this is the story about the
effects that her parents neglect has on
their children which is echoed in the
scene of him leaving her at this point
we get Nolan once more playing with time
as we see an older Murphy being played
by Ellen burstin she talks about her
father and this is taking aspects of a
documentary that appears later on at the
end of the film to recount Murphy's
childhood and also life on Earth we see
several survivors after this and these
are apparently taken from the kensburn
documentary which is called the Dust
Bowl this four hour long film Chronicles
the man-made ecological disaster which
was known as the Dust Bowl it affected
100 million acres of land in Texas and
caused a lot of health issues she talks
about how her father was a farmer and we
see a giant cornfield now Nolan loves
doing things practically and this was
seen in tenet when he crashed the plane
just for a scene this is the case in
interstellar II and rather than using
CGI for these fields he actually had 500
acres of corn planted for the film
Thrifty as ever Nolan actually sold this
once the movie was complete and he made
a profit back which you use for the
budget now we discover in the movie that
an event known as the blight has ravaged
all crops on earth except the corn this
is the only surviving food source and
cornice laced throughout almost
everything they eat Merv brings it out a
cornbread sandwich they can only get
popcorn at the baseball games and a
corny breakfast of Pancakes and chowder
is also given to them in bowls corn
syrup is also used along with corn juice
for their drinks hmm delicious corn
juice available in all good shops now
although Murph says her father was a
farmer we immediately cut to him as a
pilot referencing not only his past but
also the journey he takes in the film
Cooper is clearly very experienced which
is why he's picked Vanessa now we see
Cooper's pilot knowledge later on when
he's trying to reattach to the endurance
during the spin bran puts ahead into it
and this causes her to blackout Cooper
on the other hand turns away from it and
thus he stays conscious this pilot seems
a dream and he wakes up to find meth
standing over him Nolan often likes to
spoil his movies early on and we pointed
this out on our Prestige video with the
two opening shots in the film these told
us the twists from the opening frames
and Murph also spoils the end reveal
here
I thought you were the ghost later on we
learned that Koopa is in fact the ghost
in Murphy's room and spoiler alert
dust is also a big thing in the movie
dust everybody no dust everybody no dust
anybody no this is lace throughout how
the people live with plates being placed
upside down and tops covering Vehicles
when they're not in use the dust storms
that roll in were also done practically
as well with Nolan hiring out a real
town sand was lined along it and then
fans were put in place to blast it in to
create the effect we see in the movie
Nolan did clear it out in the end and it
adds to the realness that we see on
screen now come the end of the movie
Cooper's taken to a recreation of his
home and he's told that it's been
rebelled exactly how it was on Earth
however this isn't the case fully and
Coop runs his finger along the table for
dust which of course isn't there outside
Donald tells him about how a teacher at
his kids school is single and how he
should help repopulate the Earth might
be a reach well it is reaching but he
will end up going out to a planet at the
end which has Brand and some embryos on
it where they'll help pop like that
world now on the way to a parent-teacher
conference they see a drone drifting in
overhead in the first draft of the
script oh oh my God that's bloody
Timothy Charlemagne I forgot he was in
this anyway never mind in in the first
draft of the script the Drone was
supposed to be what Coop sent back with
the equation of how to handle the
gravity problem however this was later
changed to what we get in the final film
the Drone still is a left behind of that
and though it doesn't really serve much
of a purpose it indicates strange things
are happening at the farm just before it
swoops in Cuba explains Murphy's Law to
his daughter and how anything that can
go wrong will go wrong Murphy's Law is
something that we can't actually test
for because any test that carries it out
by Murphy's Law is doomed to fail
however in the film I think it takes a
more optimistic approach the laws of the
universe have a balance to them and thus
if things can go wrong then they can go
right too plan a and plan B in the movie
are seen as the two eventualities that
could keep the human race alive
initially plan a was that people would
venture into space and send back away
for the remaining humans to travel into
the Stars however this was thought to be
a pointless Endeavor and thus the real
plan would be Plan B this would carry
the embryos into space that could then
restart the human race in the end though
both plans come to fruition and work out
hence Murphy's Law is also the mention
of Newton's third law which states that
in order to go somewhere you have to
leave something behind kuber is of
course leaving his family behind
bringing this idea into the film's
themes and also its characters actions
now we discover later on that the Drone
is from India and this is hinted to us
when Cuba starts hacking it in a split
second shot we can see some text pop up
on screen and this is in Hindi now as we
mentioned earlier the Drone has actually
been pulled towards the home due the
gravitational anomalies that come from
the Tesseract this happens with a
combine Harvesters also being pulled
towards the house later on at school
Coop wants his son to go to college and
when this idea shut down he ends up
bringing up his taxes well the
university only takes a handful they
don't really have the resources I still
pay my taxes
and where where's that money you know
there's no more armies no no don't go to
the university in actuality these are
being siphoned off to NASA who have to
be kept on the down low because of
public opinion the government has put
out the idea that the moon landing was
fake in order to keep people grounded
and focused on being Farmers they are
deliberately discrediting the past so
that people look to the dirt Tom doesn't
want to accept this at first but over
time he starts to believe that his dad
isn't coming back and he goes back to
looking at being a farmer however Murph
doesn't and deep down she continues to
hope that her dad will return now the
teacher says okay well right now we
don't need more engineers
we didn't run out of Television screens
and planes we ran out of food and
they've also stopped putting money into
medical equipment and had MRI machines
still being developed then Cooper's
wife's tumor would have been caught
before she died now as mentioned they've
secretly been putting money into NASA so
that they can find a way to save the
human race really nice touching the book
on the table and you can see that
there's a brown stain on the top that's
caused by the dust the dust rolls in at
the Yankees game and these are pretty
crap players again due to people being
pushed into being Farmers Coop Ventures
through the dust with his family and the
sound effects used remind me a lot of
their journey through space
thank you
the truck is also very much like the
ship traveling through an inhospitable
area whilst those inside are protected
from it figuring out that the dust
leaves coordinates Kuba heads out of
there and with Murph as a stowaway nice
touch as he opens the truck door and we
can see that he's stuffed a rag in the
vents to stop the dust coming in the car
upon arriving at the base we see a sign
that says NORAD which is now what NASA
is going on there this is a real life
institution and it stands for the North
American Aerospace Defense command now
in the first of many 2001 similarities
we meet tars who is an AI that has a
voice based on Hal like how the machines
journey into space with the crew but
they don't turn evil and try and Kill
Them All
now does this call this because it's
actually an anagram of star we meet case
on the endurance and another one is
called Kip this is actually named after
cap Thorne who helped to make the film
as scientifically accurate as possible
on the front of towers we can also see
dots next to his name and this is
actually Braille to help blind people
with it other 2001 references happen
when we see the truck transition in the
spaceship as Cooper's driving away 2001
is famous for its smash cut from a bone
to a ship and this allows us to
immediately fill in the blanks of what's
happened in between there's also Koopa
seeing messages from his children on TV
which too happens in 2001 early on with
a traveler getting one from his daughter
he missed out on her birthday to
continue with his work and it's much
like how Cooper missed out on his kids
now here we're introduced to Dr brand
played by Anne Hathaway Hathaway Sports
a short haircut throughout the movie and
though it's a slick look it's actually
been done for a reason Beyond just how
it looks in zero gravity long hair would
obviously flop about and having a
shorter would save a ton on his the CGI
budget Cooper is reunited with his
daughter and we discover that NASA are
working on something known as the
Lazarus Project alongside Jesus this
biblical figure is the only person who's
come back to life and the name is picked
to talk about restarting the human race
we get a blurred picture of Matt Damon
on the wall amongst all the astronauts
but it's something he might only be able
to make out on a first watch Damon's
casting was Kept Secret so that people
weren't sitting thinking where the hell
is Matt Damon instead of focusing on the
plot this is the same with Casey Affleck
and also Topher Grace bran senior takes
Kuba for a tour and he explains the two
plans and the one that we learned was a
lie on a second watch Kane's performance
takes on a whole new meaning and we
understand what really drives him he
weaponizes the idea that Murph and her
generation will die if they stay on
Earth which pushes Coop forward he knows
that a parent will want to save their
child as he himself also does this bran
senior then sends his daughter into
space because he knows that's the best
way for her to have a chance Kane also
has some incredible mannerisms in the
movie that you only pick up on a second
watch He's evasive when people get too
close to learning the truth and he acts
very sheepish around certain
conversation topics Koopa gives his
goodbyes and also says
I can't be your girls right now
eventually he of course will be and even
the books falling don't stop him from
going love the little goodbye he has
with Tom and it's very much him saying
that he's the man of the house now he
lifts the blankets up in his car and
while Smurf was hiding under them last
time she's no longer there they make it
to the endurance and it's designed like
most ships where everything is
symmetrical this is so that things can
be operated no matter what orientation
the person on board has at this point we
hear the poem Do Not Go Gentle into that
good night by Dylan Thomas Do Not Go
Gentle into that good night
rage rage against the dying of the light
this is about how life is precious and
that it should be fought for this is
something that Coop later adopts against
man and man even drops the poem whilst
all this is going on
into that good night
old age
should burn and Rave at clothes of day
now they go down for a long nap and upon
waking up we can see Kuba winding his
watch this is one that keeps ticking and
it winds because of movement and due to
him sleeping this would have completely
stopped at this point they hit Saturn
and then travel into the black hole lots
of similarities to contact with this
scene and we see his time and space
folds around them in order to propel
them out of the Galaxy they have three
planets to visit and no prizes for
guessing the first one it doesn't end up
going well for them as they head down we
hear
just like reckless driving this pays off
later too and Coop has to dock the
endurance Cooper
is no time for caution as I'm sure you
can guess this planet fascinates me I
love the way that the water is so
shallow because it's being sucked up to
create the giant tidal waves there's a
desperate Run for the ship and as it's
hit we catch tars prepping itself to
hold Brown in place they lose decades
and also Doyle we see an astronaut face
down in the water as they escape the
planet and what really works about the
scene is that we don't know who this is
this could be Doyle however it could
just as easily be Miller due to the time
dilation Upon returning back to the ship
they find romley who's now a Broken Man
Cuba also gets messages from his
children and he misses out on Tom
meeting his first love him having his
first child and we also learned that
they sadly died you to the blight Donald
passed away too and we watch him go from
an optimistic child to a devastated
adult in seconds they name their second
child Coop after him but he's not been
there for his son throughout his hottest
moments we then see a message from
Murphy tells her that she's the same age
as her dad was when he left then spend
some time with her and Professor brand
he discusses how all the rivets they're
pumping into ships could have been
bullets and we learned that the
government actually wanted to slaughter
some of the population to make it easier
on the rest brand Elia talked about NASA
dropping bombs from the sky but he's got
them all pulling together because they
believe they can survive to Professor
brand the LIE is a positive so that
people have hope and he further avoids
Talk of the equation and how it's not
really working upon discovering that
bran had a thing with Edmonds they
decide to head to man for a look at
man's ugly side it's Man Vs man man
being the reason for his own demise and
all of the man puns that you can think
of man Damon [ __ ] sake now bran brings
up how love is a force that we can't
really quantify it's something that
exists across all dimensions in space I
feel like Nolan is very much trying to
almost give us signs to our emotions to
explain what drives the characters in
this journey back at the farm we see as
the blight returns whilst the sibling
and share some corn on the cob Murphy
learns of the lion Brand's deathbed and
it's a chilling chilling scene to know
the planet is doomed mirth is desperate
to know whether Cooper knew and left her
there to die but she doesn't get an
answer from here we see
we obviously learned that the great and
apparently noble man wasn't really the
best of us but he truly demonstrates
what humanity is selfish cowardly and
happy to bring others down with him he's
given the green light even though he's
on a planet that's doomed things are
suspicious from the off but the world
being so cold that even the clouds are
frozen Kip is dismantled as well with
man saying that he started to degenerate
humans obviously have suspicion of AI
and even most of the early interactions
with tars are laced with the idea that
things could go wrong Nolan is once more
playing on the plot line with Hal in
2001 and using our assumptions to make
us trust man more than the machines I
love Damon's performances he comes out
of the Sleep sack you can see genuine
Leaf mixed with sorrow and happiness
he's been through a lot and he drops his
iconic line
pray you never learned
just how good it can be to see another
face at this point they learn the truth
about Plan B another nice subtle detail
is our professor brand calls it Plan B
to make it sound like it's a fullback
option he knows Humanity won't work
together if they don't think there's
hope and thus he makes it sound like
this is the one they don't want to
resort to when really this is the main
plan back on Earth Murph refuses to give
up and she also carries the secret
because she knows if the truth is
revealed that people will Panic yeah we
get a further shot of the bookcase and
can also see Moby Dick metaphorically
this is about an unsurmountable force of
nature that's impossible to overcome
much like what they're facing on Earth
at this point they decide to send tars
into the singularity in order to Glimpse
the core of the black hole so they can
send data back to Earth he heads out
with Cooper and you might notice that
you can see the ground through the
landscape as they travel out this is
because they're actually walking on
Frozen clouds which makes the Landscapes
themselves on Earth we see his mirth
goes back to her room and in a flashback
we won't watch your Placer watch on the
bookcase to the left we see a book
titled the big nowhere and to the right
is a biography of Charles lindenberg he
was a pilot much like Cooper and the big
nowhere is what Cooper is currently in
during this scene as he's behind the
case in the Tesseract that's a tiny one
wibbly wobbly stuff but technically he's
here whilst also being with man now I
love the mirroring of the environments
here with the inhospitable atmosphere of
mans being almost uninhabitable like
Earth is this is the same as back on the
farm but Tom's wife and child having
breathing problems due to the air on the
farm becoming corrupted man's true
nature is revealed and he gave a thumbs
up because he was afraid of being left
alone doomed to die by himself the
astronauts were picked for the Lazarus
Mission because they didn't have any
attachments to Earth however Humanity as
a species at its core is a social one
and this man ended up reaching out
Detachment from humans is often seen as
a necessity for space travel and during
the Russian space dog program Strays
were picked to be part of of the
missions this is because they didn't
have an attachment to an owner and
therefore wouldn't suffer from the
anxiety that would come from being a pot
Professor brand kept the truth secret
because he knew that people wouldn't
work together for the betterment of
their fellow man if they didn't have
some stake in it too man actually knew
the truth and he demonstrates that bran
was correct by pulling the astronauts in
for his selfish needs mirth is forced
from the farm and he drives along a
queue of people heading to live
underground we get a quick cut of some
kids on the back of a truck and the girl
here is actually Christopher Nolan's
real-life daughter Flora Nolan had to
spend some time away from his own
daughter in order to make a career in
Hollywood and I think having her brought
out to this set is very much him making
it so the pair can spend some time
together man starts to play up that he's
actually the good guy in this situation
and I love this line
come out of the 50 50k you're gonna kill
yourself
those are the best shots I've heard in
years this is at the point where he does
Do Not Go Gentle into that good night
and this later appears at the end of the
plaque as we see Cuba being shown about
the station Merv drives back out of the
farm and she cuts through the cornfield
echoing the earlier Journey from the
movie She Burns part of the field
mirroring the beginning of the film in
which a neighboring Farmer's field was
set on fire to show crops were dying out
Cooper chose to farm corn which is why
he lasted longer and this is why Tom
sees this as being such an important
issue Romney then starts up Kev and the
robot explodes killing him in the
process however tarz survives unscathed
thinning out how he's built to
experience extreme conditions and can
also survive a black hole couldn't
really but this is a movie now in space
man's kill referee fails to dock due to
the auto docking system being disabled
he is warned about this but similar to
the helmet line he'd rather take the
risk against the low odds because he's
got nothing else at this point the
explosion has no sound and that's
because it exists in space
there is a moment
I'm after messing up the dark we get the
best scene in the movie
[Music]
completely love the score here Zimmer
knocked it out the park and the visuals
and iMacs on the OLED with a 4K Blu-ray
I was like God damn now sadly the
insurance is slipping towards Gargantua
and thus they use the gravity of the
black hole in order to slingshot brand
around to Edmonds Planet Apollo 13 had
something similar carried out in order
to return home after the mission went to
Rye they swung around the Moon to throw
themselves back as they weren't able to
land on the surface we see the Escape
thrusters being fired and get a
split-second shot of their names the
lmao1 and lmao2 I was laughing my ass
off during this and a maybe Nolan he
maybe does have a sense of humor even
though everyone says he doesn't but I
think he does now the ending of
interstellar is summing it still
confuses people but I believe it's more
straightforward than people think who
watches Cooper travels in the black hole
which someone Echoes the journey at the
end of 2001. this takes Cooper into the
Tesseract which is a term that's gained
popularity with the MCU but it's been
about way longer than that a tesseract
is a four-dimensional cube and it's what
Kuba moves through when he's behind the
bookcase as humans we see things in
three dimensions with the fourth
dimension being time hence why this
shape was picked now the way I see the
ending is that the humans from the
future had traveled into the fourth
dimension and they could see all of time
in space this is much like when you pick
up a book and you can see the story and
move both forwards and backwards in it
you can jump to any point and said story
and you you're able to travel through it
without restrictions however you can't
actually influence the events of the
story and it will always play out the
exact same way the characters in the
book are the ones experiencing it and
this is very much the case with Cooper
and the book is the device in which the
story plays out which in interstellar is
what the Tesseract is Cooper is the
character in it who can influence the
events and the 5th dimensional humans of
the readers that are basically what we
see playing out the film is a similar
metaphor too do and much like how we can
watch Cooper and jump about from scene
to scene they're able to do the same
thing they've created the device for
Cooper to travel through but they can't
really do it themselves which is why
they don't just send a direct message
telling us what to do if they did it
would also create a paradox as the
events in the film need to play out the
exact same way in order for them to play
out the way they do hopefully that makes
sense but this is why Coop can't stop
himself leaving at this point Murph puts
a hand on the buck case and she touches
one written by Diana Gabaldon this is
the author of Outlander which too
features time travel working with tarz
he passes on the message to his daughter
on how to crack the gravity equation
they put it into her watch and upon
leaving her earlier in the movie he put
a watch side by side with his to talk
about the passage of time this Memento
has brought with it the morse code on
how to save humanity and Murph figures
it out
okay
Kuba gives the first handshake to brand
and he's dropped off besides Saturn
which is where he's picked up as
mentioned earlier things like MRI
machines in complex Hospital equipment
weren't worked on because of the lack of
food here we see though that Cooper
station is packed with them due to
humanity once more focusing on
technology this is also how Murph has
been able to live for so long because
Medical Care is now far more improved as
I've been saying it's called Cooper
station and Coop assumes it's named
after him but it's actually after mirth
we see the plaque mentioned earlier and
it shows how little Humanity actually
knows about the mission due to thinking
everyone gave their lives man is on
there as well showcasing how they don't
even know about his betrayal of all the
people left a bran is the last survivor
and she's now reached Edmond's Planet
Cuba has some time back on the porch
with tars echoing earlier shots with
Donald and he says his line I don't care
much for this pretending we're back
where we started
I want to know where we are again this
is showcasing one of the reasons that he
ends up heading out finally he's
reunited with his daughter look I'm not
crying oh cry
now we see she's had countless children
and grandchildren showing that Humanity
has grown rather than dying off the pair
say their goodbyes and he fulfills his
promise to see his daughter again no
parent should watch their child die
unless he heads out in the stars in
order to join brand we catch her on a
planet that looks more similar to the
rocky lands of Earth but Edmonds died
before she managed to reach him she
buries him and with Paws in his fighter
suit Cooper heads out there be clouds
out with her walking towards the camp
which is a bright beaming light it's
only small but it offers a glimpse at
what's to come in the future plan B is
going to start there and both Cooper and
brand will be the Adam and Eve of this
new world they're the people who left
the quote-unquote paradise they had and
went out in the harsh Wasteland after
discovering knowledge and had to make
their own way that ends the movie and it
also ends our breakdown too I really
hope you enjoyed it as a lot of work
went into it and again a huge thank you
for checking the video out you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out I'll break down of The
Prestige which will be linked on screen
right now that's another Nola movie
that's got a lot going on with it and
hopefully you'll see over there right
after this also enjoy the rest of your
week thanks for sticking to the end you
take care yourself adios peace